>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SET TO GIVE A
PRIME TIME ADDRESS CALLING ON
CONGRESS TO PASS NEW GUN CONTROL
LAWS.
BIDEN WILL DEMAND ACTION AFTER
THE SCHOOL SHOOTING IN UVALDE
TEXAS THAT KILLED 19 STUDENTS
AND TWO TEACHERS.
AND AFTER THE TRAGEDY IN TULSA
OKLAHOMA WHERE A GUNMAN KILLED
FOUR PEOPLE AT A MEDICAL OFFICE,
THE PRESIDENT EXPECTED TO TWIST
THE ARM OF CONGRESS, EVEN THOUGH
HE HAS BEEN AWOL DURING THE
CURRENT SENATE NEGOTIATIONS AND
IS HEADED TO THE BEACH IN
DELAWARE TONIGHT.
THE WHITE HOUSE GETTING GRILLED
ON HOW THE PRESIDENT PLANS TO
PRESS AHEAD.
>> IF THE PRESIDENT THINKS THAT
CONGRESS MUST ACT IMMEDIATELY TO
END THIS EPIDEMIC OF GUN
VIOLENCE, IS HE GOING TO BRING
ANY OF THE KEY PLAYERS TO
CAPITOL HILL TO THE BEACH WITH
HIM TONIGHT?
>> OH, OKAY.
SO I DON'T HAVE --
>> A BIG PART OF BIDEN'S WHOLE
THING THAT HE KNOWS HOW TO GET
THINGS DONE.
>> HE DOES.
HE'S BEATEN THE GUN LOBBY
BEFORE.
>> MEANWHILE FIREWORKS ON KIRILL
AS HOUSE DEMOCRATS CLASH WITH
REPUBLICANS ON NEW GUN
LEGISLATION BEING PUSHED BY THE
LEFT.
>> THERE'S SOMETHING GUN CRAZED
ABOUT OUR COUNTRY WE NEED TO
DEAL WITH.
>> YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BULLY
YOUR WAY INTO STRIPPING
AMERICANS OF FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS.
>> IF THE SUPREME COURT OBJECTS
WE WILL EXPAND IT AND WE WILL
NOT REST UNTIL WE TAKE WEAPONS
OF WAR OUT OF CIRCULATION.
>> THEY WANT TO CHANGE THE
COUNTRY IN SO MANY WAYS.
>> IT'S FILLED WITH GOOD GUYS
WITH GUNS BUT THAT COULDN'T SAVE
THE LIVES OF 19 CHILDREN AND TWO
TEACHERS.
>> SO THIS GUN WOULD BE BANNED.
>> NO I HOPE THAT GUN IS NOT
LOADED.
>> I'M AT MY HOUSE I CAN DO
WHATEVER I WANT.
>> TO MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES I
ASK WHO ARE YOU HERE FOR?
ARE YOU HERE FOR OUR KIDS?
OR ARE YOU HERE FOR THE KILLERS?
>> OH, THAT WAS A LOW BLOW.
THE REPUBLICANS BELIEVE IN THE
SECOND AMENDMENT JESSE SIDE WITH
THE KILLERS OF CHILDREN.
THAT'S WHEN IT GETS RIDICULOUS.
>> Jesse: YEAH, HE'S A NASTY GUY
I DON'T CARE WHAT HE SAYS.
BIDEN HAS THREE THINGS HE NEEDS
TO ADDRESS TONIGHT.
THERE'S THREE COMPONENTS.
THERE'S SCHOOL SHOOTINGS, THERE
ARE MASS SHOOTINGS AND THEN
THERE ARE THESE INNER CITY GUN
HOMICIDES.
IF HE JUST GOES IN AND ONLY
ADDRESSES AR-15s, THE WHOLE
COUNTRY'S GOING TO DISMISS THAT.
WE ARE.
BECAUSE THIS IS A LARGER ISSUE.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT IT
STATISTICALLY, MOST OF THE
HOMICIDES ARE HANDGUN HOMICIDES
BY DRUG GANGS IN THE INNER CITY.
HE NEEDS TO SAY THAT, AND HE
NEEDS TO TAKE A HOE LIST
PARTICULAR APPROACH.
GREG LIKES TO TALK ABOUT
VARIABLES.
YOU CAN EVEN ADDRESS ALL THREE
OF THESE COMPONENTS IF HE LIKES
TO DO THE ROOT CAUSE THING I
KNOW HOW MUCH THEY LIKE ROOT
CAUSES.
GO INTO MENTAL HEALTH AND BROKEN
FAMILIES, GO TO THE TOXIC
INTERNET CULTURE, RED FLAGS.
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS YOU CAN
PUT OUT ON THE TABLE AND WE
EXPECT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TO DO THAT.
HE NEEDS TO COME WITH CONCRETE
PROPOSALS TONIGHT THAT CAN
ACTUALLY GET TRACTION IN THE
SENATE.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THE SENATE'S
CUT HIM OUT OF THE NEGOTIATIONS.
IF HE COMES IN AND JUST POISON
PILLS THIS THING AND SAYS
REPUBLICANS WANT EVERYONE TO
DIE, I'M GOING TO TAKE YOUR
GUNS, NO.
RIGHT NOW THEIR MAIN ACTION IN
THE SENATE IS LINDSEY GRAHAM,
CORNYN AND MITCH McCONNELL AND
BASICALLY RED FLAG LAWS.
IF THEY CAN GET ACTION ON RED
FLAG LAWS AND GET MOMENTUM ON
HARDENING SCHOOLS, TAKE THE WIN,
MR. PRESIDENT.
DON'T JUST KILL IT BECAUSE
YOU'RE REALLY SO DUG IN ON THE
LEFT THAT YOU HAVE TO GO TAKE
OUR GUNS.
TAKE THE WIN ON THAT LITTLE
ISSUE AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WILL ACTUALLY SAY, YOU KNOW
WHAT?
YOU DID SOMETHING.
EVERYONE SAYS DO SOMETHING, DO
SOMETHING.
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING.
>> DON'T YOU THINK, JESSICA,
THAT IT REALLY IS KIND OF
AMAZING THAT, AS GREG HAS BEEN
SAYING FOR WEEKS NOW, THE
PRESIDENT HAS LIKE A ONE
FACETTED APPROACH, YOU'VE GOT TO
TAKE THE GUNS.
YOU HAVE A BABY NOW.
I WOULD ASSUME THAT YOU WOULD
WANT SCHOOLS HARDENED.
YOU WOULD WANT TO KNOW ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, YOU WOULD WANT RED
FLAG LAWS TO BE IN PLACE SO WHEN
SOMEONE SHOWS ALL OF THE SIGNS
THAT WHEN WE LOOK BACK WE SEE
ALL THE CRUMBS THAT KIND OF LED
UP TO THIS THAT THERE'S GOT TO
BE MORE THAN JUST LETS GET RID
OF BASICALLY THE SECOND
AMENDMENT
>> Jessica: IT HAS TO BE A MULTI
VARIABLE APPROACH FOR SURE BUT
IN TERMS OF HARDENING SCHOOLS
SOME OF THE THINGS I HAVE E
HEARD THAT GOES INTO IT LIKE
TEACHERS BEING ARMED I DON'T
WANT THAT AND I DON'T WANT THAT
FOR MY CHILD.
>> FORGET ABOUT TEACHERS BEING
ARMED
>> Jessica: BUT THAT'S A BIG
PART OF WHAT PEOPLE ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
>> LET'S TAKE THAT OUT, YOU
BELIEVE IN HARDENING SCHOOLS
>> Jessica: I BELIEVE IN
INCREASED SECURITY SO DOES THE
BEEP TALKS AND CHRIS MURPHY PUTS
OUT THAT THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
OPEN TO INCREASED MENTAL HEALTH
PROVISIONS, ANYTHING RED FLAG
LAWS, INCREASED SECURITY AS WELL
AS EXPANDING BACKGROUND CHECKS.
NOT EVEN THE FULL MONTE OF WHAT
THEY'VE WOULDN'TED BUT THE
TINIEST INCREMENTAL MOVES
TOWARDS MAKING SOCIETY SAFER AND
THAT'S WHAT EVERYONE THAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT ALL WEEK AT
THIS TABLE.
AND THAT'S WHAT CHRIS MURPHY IS
PUTTING OUT THERE AND YOU KNOW
SOMEONE THE GUY WHO REPRESENTS
THE SANDY HOOK FAMILIES IS
PUTTING OUT THERE SOMETHING THE
DEMOCRATS ARE OPEN TO AND THAT'S
A GOOD SIGN.
BUT NO TEACHERS WITH GUNS, THAT
IS NOT THEIR JOB.
>> OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
BUT THE POINT IS THERE IS A
CHANCE TO NEGOTIATE KATIE.
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO'S ON HIS
WAY TO THE BEACH.
YESTERDAY HE'S TALKING ABOUT
HANDGUNS.
>> YEAH, I'LL PREFACE THIS
CONVERSATION BY SAYING I DO SOME
SOCIAL MEDIA WORK WITH FIREARMS
ON MY PERSONAL CAPACITY ON MY
SOCIAL MEDIA PAGES.
THAT BEING SAID PRESS SECRETARY
WAS ASKED TODAY WHY THE
PRESIDENT IS GIVING THIS ADDRESS
TONIGHT FROM THE WHITE HOUSE IN
PRIME TIME.
SHE SAID IT'S BECAUSE HE WANTS
HIS VOICE TO BE OUT THERE ON
THIS ISSUE WHICH SAYS TO ME HE'S
NOT GOING TO OFFER MUCH NEWS.
SO LET ME TALK ABOUT WHAT I
THINK HE'S GOING TO SAY TONIGHT
AND PUT SOME FACTS ON THE TABLE
BEFORE HE SAYS THESE THINGS.
HE'S GOING TO CALL FOR AN
ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN WITHOUT
DEFINING WHAT PHILADELPHIA
ASSAULT WEAPON IS.
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
SEMIAUTOMATIC RIFLES THAT'S
SOMETHING WE CAN TALK ABOUT.
BUT THE FACTS ARE, ACCORDING TO
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
JUSTICE WHICH IS A DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE OUTLET, 77% OF MASS
SHOOTINGS ARE COMMITTED WITH
HANDGUNS.
SO IF WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
THINGS THAT ACTUALLY WORK, WE
NEED TO TALK ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
NOT JUST POLITICIANS SAYING THAT
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING FOR THE
SAKE OF DOING IT, WHICH IS VERY
DISHONEST.
I THINK THE FACTS REALLY MATTER.
THE PRESIDENT HAS ALSO TALKED
ABOUT HOW YOU WEREN'T ALLOWED TO
EARN A CANNON OR CERTAIN TYPES
OF FIREARMS WHEN THE SECOND
AMENDMENT WAS RATIFIED.
THAT IS ALSO NOT TRUE.
AND SO WHEN IT COMES TO, YOU
KNOW, ISSUES OF ACTUALLY GETTING
THINGS DONE, THERE ARE CERTAIN
THINGS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT JUST CANNOT DO.
AND, YOU KNOW, WHEN IT COMES TO
ACCUSING REPUBLICANS OF BEING
PRO KID KILLER, IT'S A
NON-STARTER COMPLETELY.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T KNOW
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A NINE
MILLIMETER HANDGUN ROUND AND
WHAT THE DEFINITION OF AN
ASSAULT RIFLE IS, THAT'S ALSO A
PROBLEM.
ALSO THERE'S A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHAT THE MEDIA'S BEEN
SAYING AND PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON,
DC ARE SAYING AND WHAT THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY THINKS.
YOU GUYS PUT A POLL OUT JUST
THIS WEEK SAYING ACTUALLY MOST
PEOPLE DO THINK TEACHERS SHOULD
BE ARMED, ADMINISTRATORS SHOULD
BE ARMED.
THIS IS NOT A FOREIGN CONCEPT
THIS IS HAPPENING IN PLACES LIKE
UTAH AND TEXAS AND ARIZONA.
THIS HAS BEEN DONE.
NOBODY'S BEING FORCED TO DO IT
BUT IT IS A CONCEPT THAT A LOT
OF AMERICANS HAVE EMBRACED AS A
SOLUTION AT THEIR LOCAL LEVEL IN
THEIR SCHOOL DISTRICT.
SO IT'S A COMPLICATED ISSUE.
THE LOWEST TENDS TO THROW A
LABEL ON EVERYTHING AND ACT LIKE
THERE'S A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
POLICY.
THE MENTAL HEALTH IS IMPORTANT
BUT THEN WE GET INTO ISSUES OF
VETERANS NOT SEEKING MENTAL
HEALTHCARE BECAUSE THEY MIGHT
NOT BE ABLE TO EXERCISE THEIR
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS SO IT'S
A COMPLICATED ISSUE THE
PRESIDENT IS GOINGS TO TALK
ABOUT BECAUSE HE WANT TO MAKE
HIS VOICE HEARD BEFORE HE GOES
TO THE BEACH FOR THE WEEKEND
WHICH SAYS THE URGENCY IS NOT
THAT BAD.
>> GREG, IT'S KIND OF
INTERESTING, IN ISRAEL, YOU
KNOW, YOU DON'T HEAR A LOT ABOUT
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS THERE AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY'VE HARDENED
THE SCHOOLS.
THEY HAVE ONE ENTRANCE.
YOU GO THROUGH ONE ENTRANCE.
ALL THE TEACHERS ARE ARMED.
AND THEY DON'T PUBLICIZE IT.
BUT PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY ARE
NOT EVEN WILLING TO TALK ABOUT
CERTAIN ASPECTS OF PROTECTION WE
CAN ALL AGREE ON.
THERE IS COMMON GROUND ISN'T
THERE?
>> Greg: I THINK SO BUT YOU
CAN'T FIND COMMON GROUND WITH
PEOPLE YOU DON'T TRUST AND BOTH
SIDES KIND OF DON'T TRUST EACH
OTHER.
I THINK THERE'S A FAIRLY GOOD
REASON WHY PEOPLE WHO ARE STRONG
ON THE SECOND AMENDMENT DON'T
TRUST THE OTHER SIDE BECAUSE THE
OTHER SIDE'S WRONG ON EVERY
VARIABLE.
LIKE YOU SAID, YOU KNOW, BIDEN'S
BEEN AROUND A LONG TIME AND THE
GUY IS SO IGNORANT AND INSULTING
WHEN IT COMES TO TALKING ABOUT
GUNS.
YOU CANNOT TAKE HIM SERIOUSLY.
THE REASON WHY HE'S STICKS TO
ONE VARIABLE BECAUSE THAT'S THE
ONLY ONE HE CAN HANDLE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'LL GET
FROM BIDEN TONIGHT BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S LEFT OF HIM.
RIGHT?
SOMEBODY'S PULLING HIS STRINGS.
IF I WERE A KILLER I WOULD GO TO
A GUN FREE ZONE BECAUSE THE
AMOUNT OF DEATH IS MITIGATED BY
THE SECOND GUN ARRIVING.
THAT'S THE SCIENCE, RIGHT?
SO TO YOUR STATISTIC, IT'S TRUE.
MOST AMERICANS FAVOR THEIR
TEACHERS HAVING GUNS.
I FAVOR IT.
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE WOULD THINK
THAT TEACHERS CAN'T HANDLE IT,
UNLESS THEY'RE ON TIK TOK.
IF THE TEACHERS ARE ON TIK TOK
THEY GET NO GUNS.
THAT IS THE RED FLAG, A TEACHER
ON TIK TOK TALKING ABOUT GENDER,
NO GUN FOR YOU.
BUT I DO THINK THAT LIKE RATHER
THAN FOCUS ON THE END RESULT,
WHICH IS ALWAYS THE CASE.
I HATE SAYING SINGLE VARIABLE
BECAUSE I SOUND LIKE A BROKEN
RECORD BUT IT'S ALWAYS THE GUN.
THERE'S ALL THESE STEPS WHETHER
SCHOOL SECURITY, RED FLAGS,
SOCIAL MEDIA, WHICH IS AN ISSUE
IN THE LAST 15-20 YEARS.
SOCIAL MEDIA IS ONE OF THE MOST
PRACTICE INITIALS PARTS OF THIS
RECIPE IN ALL SORTS OF VIOLENCE,
BUT THERE'S A REASON WHY I THINK
THAT THE LEFT STAYS AWAY FROM
OTHER VARIABLES.
IT'S BECAUSE THEIR FINGERPRINTS
ARE ALL OVER A CULTURE THAT
UNDERMINES CERTAIN INSTITUTIONS
THAT HAVE ALLOWED THESE THINGS
TO HAPPEN.
YOU KNOW, WHERE IS FAMILY?
WHERE IS RELIGION?
I'M NOT RELIGIOUS BUT I CAN
UNDERSTAND THE ROLE THAT IT
PLAYS IN PEOPLE'S LIVES AND IT'S
A POSITIVE ROLE.
IT'S A POSITIVE ONE.
AND I'M AGNOSTIC AND I SAY THAT.
RELIGION, FAMILY, MENTAL HEALTH,
I KNOW JESSICA AND I AGREE ON
MENTAL HEALTH.
THE SECURITY OF THE SCHOOLS.
THAT MAKES TOTAL SENSE.
BUT YOU CANNOT ADDRESS THESE
THINGS IF YOU FEEL IN YOURSELF
THAT SOMEHOW YOU HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THIS UNTETHERED
ALIENATION THAT WE SEE RIGHT NOW
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY THE LEFT
TURNS AWAY FROM A LOT OF THESE
OTHER POSSIBILITIES.
BUT, A CHILD -- LIKE A LARGE
BILL THAT WOULD TACKLE
EVERYTHING WOULD CREATE TRUST.
SO THAT IF YOU WENT AFTER A
CERTAIN SEGMENT GUN, LIKE AN
AGE -- YOU KNOW, AN AGE MINIMUM
FOR A RIFLE.
NOT AN ASSAULT RIFLE BECAUSE
THAT DOESN'T EXIST, BUT A RIFLE,
AND THEN YOU PUT IN SOCIAL MEDIA
AND THEN YOU PUT IN HARDENING
THE SCHOOLS AND THEN YOU PUT IN
RED FLAGS, THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO
TRUST EACH OTHER BECAUSE IT'S
MORE THAN ONE VARIABLE.
IF IT'S JUST SOMEBODY TALKING
ABOUT ONE THING ALL THE TIME YOU
CAN'T TRUST THEM